Es un gran honor estar aquí con ustedes.
La buena noticia es que
Yo estoy muy conciente de mi responsabilidad de sacarlos de aquí,
porque yo soy lo único que esta entre ustedes y el bar.
(Risas)
Y la buena noticia es que no tengo un discurso preparado,
pero tengo una caja de diapositivas.
Tengo algunas fotos que representan mi vida y a lo que me dedico.
He aprendido por experiencia
que la gente recuerda imágenes mucho después de olvidar las palabras.
Así que espero que recuerden algunas de las fotos
que voy a compartir con ustedes por unos minutos.
La historia empieza en realidad
conmigo como estudiante de secundaria en Pittsburg, Pensilvania,
en un barrio difícil al que todos dieron por muerto.
Y en un miércoles por la tarde
estaba caminando por un corredor de mi secundaria,
metido en mi cosas, y ahi estaba este artista dando clases,
quien estaba haciendo un gran jarrón de cerámica.
Y yo justo estaba mirando por la puerta del aula de arte.
Si alguna vez han visto cómo se trabaja la arcilla, es mágico,
y yo nunca antes había visto algo igual en mi vida.
Entonces, entré al aula y dije: “¿Qué es eso?”
Y él dijo: “Cerámica - ¿ y tú quién eres?”
Yo dije: “Soy Bill Strickland. Quiero que me enseñes a hacer eso.”
Y él dijo: “Bueno, consigue un papel firmado por tu profesor
que diga que puedes venir y yo te enseñaré.”
Y entonces, los últimos dos años de la secundaria,
falté a todas mis clases.
(Risas)
Pero tuve la astucia
de darles la cerámica que hice a los profesores de las clases a las que falté—
(Risas)
y me aprobaron.
Y así terminé la secundaria.
Y el Sr. Ross dijo:
“Eres demasiado listo para morir, y no quiero eso pesando en mi conciencia,
así que estoy dejando esta escuela y te llevo conmigo.”
Y me llevó a la Universidad de Pittsburg
donde llené la solicitud de ingreso y entré a prueba.
Bueno, ahora soy Miembro del Consejo de la Universidad
y en la ceremonia de instalacion dije:
“Soy el tipo que vino del barrio
quien entró en el lugar a prueba.
No se den por vencidos con los jóvenes pobres porque nunca saben
qué les va a pasar a esos jóvenes en la vida.”
Lo que les voy a mostrar por unos minutos
es un complejo que construí en el peor barrio de Pittsburg
con la más alta tasa de crimen.
Uno se llama Centro de Capacitación Bidwell, es una escuela vocacional
para ex trabajadores siderúrgicos y padres solteros y madres con asistencia social.
¿Recuerdan que solíamos producir acero en Pittsburg?
Bueno, ya no producimos mas acero
y la gente que solía producir el acero
está pasando por un momento muy duro por esto.
Y yo los reconstruyo y les doy vida nueva.
La Asociación de Artesanos Manchester se llama así por mi barrio.
Y fui adoptado
por el Obispo de la Diócesis Episcopal durante los disturbios.
Y él donó una casa adosada y en esa casa
fundé la Asociación de Artesanos Manchester.
Y aprendí rápidamente que donde hay Episcopales,
hay dinero en las proximidades.
(Risas)
Y el Obispo me adoptó como a un hijo.
Y el año pasado hablé en su ceremonia conmemorativa
y le deseé lo mejor en esta vida.
Salí y contraté a un estudiante de Frank Lloyd Wright, el arquitecto,
y le pedí que me construyera un centro de alto nivel
en el peor barrio de Pittsburg.
Mi edificio es un modelo a escala del aeropuerto de Pittsburg.
Y cuando vengan a Pittsburg – y están todos invitados–
Van a aterrizar en la versión ampliada de mi edificio.
Ese es el edificio.
Construido en un barrio difícil donde a la gente se les habia dada por muerta.
Y mi opinión es que si uno se quiere involucrar
en la vida de gente a la que se les ha dado por perdida,
uno tiene que ser como la solución y no el problema.
Como pueden ver, hay una fuente en el patio
y la razón por la cual hay una fuente en el patio es que yo quería una.
Y yo tenia la chequera asi que yo compre una y la puse ahi.
(Risas)
Y ahora que doy charlas en conferencias como TED,
me pusieron en el directorio del Museo Carnegie
y en la recepción en su patio, noté que tenían una fuente
porque ellos creen que la gente que va al museo merece una fuente.
Bueno, yo creo que las madres con asistencia social y jóvenes en riesgo
y ex trabajadores sidelúrjicos merecen una fuente en su vida.
Así que lo primero que se ve en mi centro en primavera
es agua que te da la bienvenida — agua es vida y agua de posibilidad humana.
Y establece una actitud y expectativas
sobre lo que uno siente de la gente, aun antes de darles un discurso.
Así que a partir de esa fuente construí este edificio.
Como pueden ver, tiene arte de alto nivel y todo esta mi a gusto
porque yo conseguí todo el dinero.
(Risas)
Le dije a mi hijo: “Cuando tú juntes el dinero
pondremos tu gusto en la pared.”
Pero tenemos edredones y arcilla y caligrafía
y por donde miren,
hay algo hermoso devolviéndote la mirada.
Eso es deliberado.
Eso es adrede.
En mi opinión, es este tipo de mundo
el que puede redimir el espíritu de la gente pobre.
También creamos una sala de reuniones.
Y contraté a un ebanista nipón de Kyoto, Japón,
a quien le comisioné 60 muebles para nuestro edificio.
Desde entonces, le hemos dado un giro a su propio negocio.
Está haciendo mucho dinero haciendo muebles sobre pedido para gente adinerada.
Y yo conseguí 60 piezas para mi escuela
porque sentí que madres con asistencia social y ex trabajadores siderúrgicos
y padres solteros merecían venir a una escuela
donde hubieran muebles artesanales dándoles la bienvenida todos los días
porque promueve un tono y una actitud sobre lo que uno siente de la gente
mucho antes de darles el discurso.
Hasta tenemos flores en los pasillos y no son de plástico—
esas son de verdad y están en mi edificio todos los días.
Y ahora que he dado muchos discursos,
tuvimos a un grupo de directores de secundarias y vinieron a verme
y dijeron: “Sr. Strickland,
qué gran historia y qué gran escuela.
Y nos conmovieron especialmente las flores
y nosotros tenemos curiosidad de como las flores llegaron aquí.”
Yo dije: “Bueno, subí a mi auto y fui a un invernadero
y las compré y las traje y las puse allí.”
No necesitas un grupo de trabajo o un grupo de estudio para comprarle flores a tus jóvenes.
Lo que necesitan saber es que los niños
y los adultos merecen tener flores en su vida.
El costo es fortuito pero el gesto es enorme.
Y entonces en mi edificio, el cual está lleno luz de sol y lleno de flores,
creemos en la esperanza y la posibilidad humana.
Esto sucedio en Navidad.
Así que lo próximo que van a ver es una cocina de un millón de dólares
que fue construida por la empresa Heinz. ¿Han oido hablar de ellos?
Les fue muy bien con el negocio del ketchup.
Y casualmente conozco muy bien a esta empresa
porque John Heinz, quien fue nuestro senador
–quien murió trágicamente en un accidente de aviacion–
se enteró de mi deseo de construir un nuevo edificio
porque yo tenía una caja de cartón y la puse en una bolsa de plastico
y caminé por todo Pittsburg tratando de juntar dinero para este lugar.
Y me llamó a su oficina
–que es como ir a ver al Mago de Oz–
(Risas)
Y John Heinz tenía 600 millones de dólares y yo en ese entonces tenía como 60 centavos.
Y él dijo: “Pero hemos oido acerca de Ud.
Hemos oido sobre su trabajo con jóvenes y ex trabajadores siderúrgicos,
y estamos dispuestos a apoyar su aspiración de construir un nuevo edificio.
Y usted nos podria hacer un gran servicio
si pudiera incluir un programa culinario en su programa”—
porque en ese entonces estábamos armando un programa de oficios.
Dijo: “Así podremos cumplir nuestros objetivos de acción afirmativa
para la compañia Heinz.”
Yo dije: “Senador, estoy reacio a entrar en un campo
del cual no sé mucho, pero le prometo
que si apoya a mi escuela, yo la construiré
y en un par de años volveré
a considerar este programa que Ud. quiere.”
El senador Heinz estaba sentado en silencio y dijo:
“Bueno, ¿cuál sería su reacción
si yo dijera que le daré un millón de dólares?”
Yo dije: “Senador, parece que vamos a dedicarnos a la capacitación gastronómica.”
(Risas)
Y John Heinz me dio un millón de dólares.
Y lo más importante,
me prestó al director de investigación de la compañia Heinz.
Y más o menos tomamos prestado el programa de estudio del Instituto Culinario de America,
el cual es para ellos es como el Harvard de las escuelas culinarias.
Y creamos un programa de chefs gourmet para madres en asistencia social
en esta cocina de millón de dólares en medio de un barrio marginal.
Y nunca más miramos atrás.
Ahora me gustaría mostrarles algo de la comida
que estas madres en asistencia social hacen en esta cocina de millón de dólares.
Esta es nuestra cafetería.
Ese es día del hojaldre. ¿Por qué?
Porque los estudiantes hicieron hojaldre
y eso es lo que la escuela come todos los días.
Pero el concepto era que quería quitarle el estigma a la comida.
Que la buena comida no es para jente rica—
la buena comida es para todos en el planeta
y no hay excusas para que no podamos comerla todos.
Asi que en mi escuela, subsidiamos un programa de almuerzo gourmet
para madres con asistencia social en medio de un barrio marginal
porque descubrimos que es bueno para sus estómagos,
pero es mejor para sus cabezas.
Porque yo quería que supieran todos los días de su vida
que tienen valor en este lugar que yo llamo mi centro.
Tenemos estudiantes que se sientan juntos, negros y blancos,
y lo que descubrimos es que puedes resolver un problema racial
creando un entorno de alto nivel.
Porque la gente tenderá a mostrarte un comportamiento de alto nivel
si la tratas en esa forma.
Estos son muestras que las madres en asistencia socias esta haciendo
después de seis meses en el programa de capacitación.
Sin sofisticación y sin clase, no hay dignidad ni historia.
Lo que descubrimos es que lo único malo con la gente pobre
es que no tienen dinero, lo cual es una condición curable.
Todo esta en como uno piensa uno de la jente
lo suele determinar su comportamiento.
Esto fue hecho por una estudiante después de siete meses en el programa,
hecho por una muchacha muy brillante
quien aprendió de nuestro maestro pastelero.
Yo comí siete de esas canastas y son muy buenas.
(Risas)
No tienen calorías.
Eso es nuestro comedor.
Parece la cafetería promedio de cualquier secundaria
en un pueblo promedio en Estados Unidos.
Pero esta es mi visión de cómo se debe tratar a los estudiantes,
particularmente cuando han sido hechos a un lado.
Capacitamos técnicos para la industria farmacéutica.
Capacitamos técnicos para la industria médica.
Y podemos capacitar técnicos químicos para empresas
como Bayer y Calgon Carbon y Fisher Scientific y Exxon.
Y les garantizo que si vienen a mi centro en Pittsburg
–y están todos invitados–
verán madres con asistencia social haciendo química analítica
con calculadoras logarítmicas,
10 meses después de comenzar el programa.
No hay absolutamente razón alguna por la cual la gente pobre
no pueda aprender tecnologia de alto nivel.
Lo que descubrimos es que hay que darles flores
y luz de sol y comida y expectativas y música de Herbie
y se puede siempre curar un cáncer espiritual.
Capacitamos agentes para corporaciones de la industria de viajes.
Hasta podemos enseñarle a la gente a leer.
El joven con la raya roja estaba en el programa hace dos años—
ahora es instructor.
Y tengo jóvenes de secundaria con diplomas que no pueden leer.
Así que deben hacerse la pregunta -
cómo es posible que en el siglo XXI
graduemos de la escuela a jóvenes
quienes no pueden leer los diplomas que tienen en sus manos.
La razon es que el sistema es reembolsado
por los jóvenes que avientan por el otro lado, no por los que leen.
Yo puedo tomar a estos jóvenes y en 20 semanas,
aptitud demostrada, les consigo una equivalencia de secundaria.
No es gran cosa.
Esta es nuestra biblioteca con más muebles artesanales.
Y este es el programa de arte que yo comencé en 1968.
Recuerden yo soy joven negro de los 60's quien salvó su vida con cerámica.
Bueno, cuando decidí reproducir mi experiencia
con otros jóvenes en el barrio,
bajo la teoría de que si les das flores y les das comida
y les das luz de sol y entusiasmo,
les puedes devolver la vida.
Tengo 400 jóvenes provenientes de la educación pública de Pittsburg
que vienen a mi todos los días de la semana para recibir educacion artística.
Y estos son jóvenes quienes están reprobando en la escuela pública.
Y que el año pasado puse 88% de esos jóvenes en la universidad
y he promediado arriba del 80% por los últimos 15 años.
Hemos hecho un descubrimiento fascinante -
no hay nada mal con los jovenes
que el afecto y luz de sol y la comida y el entusiasmo
y música de Herbie no pueda curar.
Por eso gané una gran placa—Hombre del Año en Educación.
Les gané a todos los doctorados
porque me di cuenta que si tratas a los jóvenes como seres humanos,
ello aumenta la probablidad de que se comporten en esa manera.
Y por qué no podemos instituir esta política
en toda escuela y en toda ciudad y todo pueblo
es aún un misterio para mí.
Déjenme mostrarles lo que esta gente hace.
Tenemos cerámica y fotografía y computación gráfica
y estos son todos jóvenes sin habilidad artística, sin talento,
sin imaginación, y traemos a los mejores artistas del mundo
–Gordon Parks estuvo aquí, Chester Higgins estuvo aquí–
y lo que aprendimos
es que los niños serán como la gente que les enseña.
De hecho, yo traje a un artista del mosaico del Vaticano,
y una mujer afro-americana
quien estudió las antiguas técnicas de mosaico del Vaticano,
y déjenme mostrarles lo que hicieron con el trabajo.
Estos son jovenes a quienes el mundo entero habia hecho a un lado
quienes estaban reprobando en la escuela pública,
y esto es de lo que son capaces de hacer
con afecto y luz del sol y comida y buena música y confianza.
Enseñamos fotografía.
Y esto es un ejemplo del trabajo de los jóvenes.
Este joven ganó una beca de 4 años
por esta foto.
Esta es nuestra galería.
Tenemos una galería de alto nivel
porque creemos que los jóvenes pobres necesitan una galería de alto nivel.
Así yo que diseñé esto.
Tenemos salmón ahumando en las inauguraciones.
Tenemos una invitación formal impresa.
y hasta encontré la manera de hacer que los padres vengan.
Hace 15 años, no podía conseguir un sólo padre.
Así que contraté a un tipo que realmente se regocijaba en Jesús.
Sacaba tipos de los bares
y salvaba esas vidas para el Señor.
Y dije: “Bill, quiero contratarte.
Tienes que bajarle un poco el tono a lo de Jesús,
pero mantén el entusiasmo.
(Risas)
No puedo hacer que estos padres vengan a la escuela.”
Él dijo: “Yo los haré venir a la escuela.”
Entonces se subió en la camioneta, fue a la casa de la Sra. Jones y dijo:
“Sra. Jones, sé que Ud. quisiera venir a la exhibicion de arte de su hijo,
pero probablemente no tenga quien la lleve.
Así que la vine a buscar.”
Y consiguió 10 padres y luego 20 padres.
Para la última exhibición que hicimos, vinieron 200 padres
y no fuimos a buscar a ninguno.
Porque ahora ya no es socialmente aceptable no venir
a apoyar a sus hijos en la Asociación de Artesanos Manchester
porque la gente creería que son malos padres.
Y no hay diferencia estadística
entre los padres blancos y los padres negros.
Las madres irán a donde sus hijos sean celebrados,
todo el tiempo, en todo pueblo, en toda ciudad.
Quería que ustedes vieran esta galería porque es de lo mejor que hay.
Y cuando estos jóvenes terminan la secundaria,
tienen 4 exhibiciones en su currículum
antes del ingreso a la universidad porque está todo aquií.
Hay que cambiar la manera en que la gente se ve a sí misma
antes de cambiar su comportamiento.
Y ha funcionado bastante bien hasta ahora.
Hasta agregué otra aula a este edificio, la cual me gustaría mostrarles.
Es totalmente nueva.
Hicimos esta diapositiva justo a tiempo para la Conferencia de TED.
Presenté estas diapositivas en un lugar llamado Silicon Valley
y me fue bien.
Y una mujer salió del público,
ella dijo: “Esa es una gran historia
y me impresionó mucho su presentación.
Mi única crítica es que sus computadoras se están poniendo viejas.”
Y yo dije: “Bueno, ¿a qué se dedica Ud.?”
Ella dijo: “Bueno, trabajo para una compañía llamada Hewlett Packard.”
Y yo dije: “ ¿Está usted en la industria informática, es asi?”
Ella dijo: “Sí, señor.”
Y yo dije: “Bueno, hay una solución simple a ese problema.”
Bueno, me complace anunciarles que HP
y una compañía mobiliaria llamada Steelcase
nos adoptaron como modelo de demonstración de toda su tecnología
y todo su mobiliario para los Estados Unidos.
Y esta es el aula.
Eso es empezar una relación.
Lo terminamos justo a tiempo para mostrárselos.
Esto sería el debut mundial de nuestro centro de computación gráfica.
(Aplausos)
(Música)
Sólo tengo un par más de diapositivas
y aquí es donde la historia se pone interesante.
Así que quiero que me escuchen por unos minutos más
y comprenderán por qué él está ahí y yo aquí.
En 1986, tuve la astucia de agregar un teatro
al extremo norte del edificio mientras lo estaba contruyendo.
Y un tipo llamado Dizzy Gillespie fue a tocar ahí
porque conocía a este hombre, Marty Ashby.
Y me paré en el escenario con Dizzy Gillespie probando el sonido
un miércoles a la tarde y dije:
“Dizzy, ¿por qué vendrías tu a un centro manejado por negros
en medio de un parque industrial con alta tasa de crimen
que ni siquiera tiene una reputación musical?”
Él dijo: “Porque escuché que construiste el centro
y no lo podía creer, y quise verlo yo mismo.
Y ahora que lo vi, quiero darte un regalo.”
Yo dije: “Tú eres el regalo.”
Él dijo: “No, señor. Tú eres el regalo.
Y te voy a permitir grabar el concierto
y te voy a dar la música.
Y si algún día eliges venderla, debes firmar un acuerdo
que diga que el dinero volvera para apoyar la escuela.”
Y yo grabé a Dizzy, y falleció un año más tarde,
pero no antes de decirle a un tipo llamado McCoy Tyner lo que estábamos haciendo.
Y él apareció y dijo:
“Dizzy está hablando de ti por todo el país, hombre,
y yo quiero ayudarte.”
Y luego un tipo llamado Wynton Marsalis apareció.
Luego un bajista llamado Ray Brown
y un tipo llamado Stanley Turrentine
y un pianista llamado Herbie Hancock
y una banda llamada Count Basie Orchestra
y un tipo llamado Tito Puente
y un tipo llamado Gary Burton y Shirley Horn y Betty Carter
y Dakota Stanton y Nancy Wilson.
Todos vinieron a este centro en medio de un parque industrial,
con llenos completos, en medio de un barrio marginal.
Me complace mucho decirles, con su permiso,
que he acumulado 600 grabaciones
de los mejores artista del mundo,
incluyendo a Joe Williams, quien falleció
habiendo hecho su última grabación en mi escuela.
Y Joe Williams se me acercó y puso su mano sobre mi hombro
y dijo: “Hombre, Dios te eligió para hacer este trabajo
y quiero que mi música esté contigo.”
Y eso funcionó muy bien .
Cuando la banda Basie vino, la banda se entusiasmaron tanto con la escuela
que votaron para darme los derechos de la música.
Y la grabé y ganamos algo llamado Grammy.
Y como un tonto, no fui a la ceremonia
porque no pensé que fuéramos a ganar.
Bueno, sí ganamos.
Y tuvimos nuestro nombre literalmente en luces en Madison Square Garden.
Luego nos visitó la Orquesta de Jazz de las Naciones Unidas y los grabamos
y los nominaron a un segundo Grammy, uno atrás del otro.
Así nos convertimos en uno de los estudios de jazz más nuevos y populares
de los Estados Unidos—
(Risas)
en medio de un barrio marginal con alta tasa de crimen.
Ese es el lugar lleno de Republicanos.
(Risas)
(Aplasos)
Si hubieran tirado una bomba en ese salón,
hubieran eliminado todo el dinero de Pensilvania
porque estaba todo sentado ahí;
incluyendo a mi madre y a mi padre, que vivieron lo suficiente
para ver a su hijo construir este edificio.
Y ahí está Dizzy, como les dije, estuvo ahí.
Y él estuvo ahí, Tito Puente,
y Pat Metheny y Jim Hall estuvieron ahí
y grabaron con nosotros.
Este fue nuestro primer estudio de grabación, que era el armario de la limpieza.
Y pusimos los trapeadores en el pasillo y rediseñamos la cosa
y ahí es donde grabamos el primer Grammy.
Este es nuestro nuevo estudio, con toda la tecnología en video.
Y esta sala fue construida a nombre de una mujer llamada Nancy Wilson,
quien grabó ese álbum en nuestra escuela la última Navidad.
Y si alguno de ustedes estaba viendo Oprah Winfrey
en Navidad, él estaba ahí y Nancy estaba ahí,
cantando partes de este álbum,
cuyos derechos donó a nuestra escuela.
Y ahora les puedo decir con toda certeza
que aparecer en Oprah Winfrey vende 10.000 CDs.
(Risas)